[Music]
on this sunday night
the war in america
the riots rage out of control i'm
frustrated
and i'm angry and and i feel powerless
the violence that has hijacked protests
across the u.s
george floyd's death brings racism to
the forefront
he's just the latest tipping point in a
string
of killings the rallying cries for
police accountability
and equal justice the accusations that
donald trump is inflaming
the unrest the president has a role to
play nationally
in calming the unrest why hasn't the
president
appealed for calm and the fury spreads
to canada
and other parts of the world
global national with robin gill
riders unleashed their rage in
minneapolis and in cities all across the
u.s
on another night of unrest it started
out with tens of thousands protesting
the death of george floyd
a black man who died monday after a
white police officer
kneeled on his neck demonstrations
extended to nearly
every corner of the country and beyond
but there are troublemakers among those
who are trying to protest peacefully
and curfews that were imposed in major
cities couldn't stop the instigators
one city after another was filled with
smoke
hundreds were arrested another night
marred by violence
on the streets of america good evening
and thank you for joining us
americans woke up to scenes of
destruction once again today
anger has been unleashed coast to coast
after the death of 46 year old
george floyd and the overall
mistreatment of black americans at the
hands of police
the scale of the protest now rivaling
historic demonstrations of the civil
rights era
and the vietnam war let's go to the u.s
capitol now and our washington bureau
chief jackson proskow who's been
following protesters as they wind
through the american capital
set the scene for us jackson
robin we're about a block away from the
white house where all afternoon long a
relatively peaceful protest had been
taking place there were some small
incidents of pepper spray being deployed
but things had been calm then the group
started to move their destination we
believe was the nearby trump hotel
but they ran up against police and
police refused to let them move
any further just in the past few minutes
we've had tear gas and flash bangs
deployed on the crowd
plenty of projectiles back and forth and
at times it touches off a stampede of
protesters
they come running to to get away from
that so really it's sort of a at a
stalemate right now
and i think people are waiting to see
where this is all going to go what kind
of a police presence is there
a huge one to put it simply there are
many overlapping police forces in
washington
the white house compound itself is
protected by secret service
out here it's dc's police that are now
maintaining the barricades and keep
keeping people from moving in certain
directions but dc has also activated its
national guard and those national guard
troops have been called up
to provide additional support especially
overnight tonight jackson you've been
watching this all day
what was it like earlier we saw that you
got caught up in some of the the crowds
yeah this is what happens it's sort of a
back and forth so things can be
very very peaceful and you see scenes
where the entire crowd of thousands will
take a knee and really
have a poignant pause in remembrance of
george floyd
and then a few agitators will come
forward they might start throwing water
bottles or bricks at police
police fire pepper spray of course when
you're in a tightly packed crowd like
this
that sets off panic and people start
running that's what happened to us
earlier
and it keeps happening throughout the
day here has the national guard been
called in
as as it has in other cities in america
it has it was called in last night to
defend the white house specifically and
the national guard has now been called
up to work with dc police to protect the
streets here
tonight it is something we're seeing in
cities across america for a specific
reason
and that is that local authorities feel
it can be a waste a way to diffuse
tensions between the local community and
the local police force
by instead bringing forward the police
brett watcher back here
so we've just got some police moving
through the area here robin
now jack and all of this is happening on
donald trump's doorstep what is the
white
house saying about this
well the president is inside the white
house tonight he has to be aware of
what's happening right outside
but he continues to tweet statements
meant to agitate the crowd he tweeted in
all caps a short time ago
law and order he's retweeting people who
are calling for a heavy-handed approach
and time and time again he has also
branded all the protesters as being what
he calls antifa which is
meant to symbolize extreme left-wing
protesters he today called for those
people to be declared a terrorist
organization but it's not a formal
organization
so it seems to be a slippery slope to
essentially criminalizing
anyone who is participating in these
protests mayors from right across the
country are
calling on him to address the nation to
appeal for calm what is he doing about
that
and reportedly there is a split within
the white house itself as to how the
president should respond to this
there are calls for him to step forward
take a leadership role and
issue that national appeal for calm but
he's not doing that he's essentially
throwing rocks in from the side
uh calling for counter protest from his
own supporters at certain points
so the question is where does this go is
the president even a factor at this
point because he's essentially been
invisible okay jackson frosco in
washington thanks jackson and stay safe
these protests have taken place in at
least 76 cities across the u.s and as
you just saw in washington the
demonstrations have degenerated
in some parts the authorities have lost
control of a crisis
that is growing as jennifer johnson
reports they're preparing for another
night
of unfettered violence
scenes of destruction in cities across
america after another night of rioting
looting and fires thousands again
ignored minneapolis's curfew and took to
the streets
police met them with tear gas and rubber
bullets the fury ignited after 46 year
old george floyd died
when minneapolis police officer derek
shaubin knelt on his neck
for almost nine minutes i do worry about
this i worry because
my human emotion the visceral response
to the erasing of the humanity
of george floyd chavin has been charged
with floyd's murder but the victim's
family and protesters are also demanding
charges
against the three other arresting
officers i'm willing to
walk scream do whatever i need to do to
let people know that i'm really i'm
tired of this
minnesota officials promising this
investigation is not over
and the other officers may face criminal
charges the
other individuals are not out of the
woods the investigation is
ongoing and we expect to hear something
in the you know fairly recent near
future floyd's death continues to spark
angry violent protests
in new york thousands took to the
streets in a city still under lockdown
from the covet 19 pandemic
police cars set on fire officers
attacked two
nypd vehicles drove into a crowd of
protesters holding a metal barricade
knocking many of them over clearly we
need to do a full investigation
and look at the actions of those
officers and see what was done and why
it was done and what could be done
differently
cities from philadelphia to los angeles
look like war zones
in washington d.c an angry mob tried
again to get over barriers
outside the white house the thing that
we're struck by
is that it was an organized group that
appeared more been on destruction
than on protests local leaders promising
to find who is responsible
for the thousands of businesses that
have been destroyed or looted
our law enforcement partners our police
department and i know
our state law enforcement partners are
working very hard to get to the bottom
of exactly who that is and what exact
agenda is behind that but the agenda for
many is an end to police brutality and
racism
and once again curfews will be in place
national guard soldiers on patrol
and police and combat gear out in force
as these riots show
no sign of ending anytime soon
jennifer johnson global news washington
the situation in the u.s is entrenched
in the history of that country
there are hundreds of other examples of
black americans being unjustly killed
as michael couture explains the u.s may
now be at a boiling point
the scenes are shocking but too familiar
to so many people
the police don't care about us they knew
exactly what they were doing in
minneapolis
and at the end of the day we had to
fight for what's right for us there's a
long list of names and places that stain
our history of race relations
rodney king in los angeles trayvon
martin in florida
michael brown in ferguson missouri it's
not just an american problem
in 2016 abdirahman abdi died after what
witnesses described
as a violent arrest by ottawa police
the protests that followed every one of
those incidents and now
george floyd's death are a manifestation
of built up anger in those communities
according to floyd's family lawyer he's
just the
latest tipping point in a string of
killings of
unarmed black people at the hands
or should i say in his case the knee of
the police
this exchange between three generations
of black men in charlotte north carolina
saturday night
an example of the ongoing struggle in
communities
across north america a 46 year old man
argues with 31 year old curtis hayes jr
i needed to let him know right then and
there that
people hear you i hear you black man
i am in the same boat that you are you
are elder of mines you have fought
the same fight that i am fighting right
here with you
but then hayes brought a 16 year old
protester into the discussion
not to fan the flames of anger but
rather to find a different path forward
so the teen
wouldn't feel the same frustration in
another 10 years putting yourself in
harm's way
it's not the way no it's not
you and then other your counterparts the
same age
has that same power y'all coming with a
better way
because we ain't doing it that's three
generations right there
that is on that bridge fighting for the
same thing
that my ancestors fought for and those
three generations sat there
a hundred years ago in the same aspect
in the same
chaos in the same america
but there are signs of hope i took the
helmet off they laid the batons down
yeah i want to make this a parade in
flint michigan saturday night instead of
cracking down on protesters
local sheriff tried to lift them up
so sheriff chris swanson did taking a
small step
to perhaps a better future mike
lacrouter global news
canada is not immune to issues of race
there is systemic racism
facing our indigenous populations asian
communities
and african canadians and tonight there
are protests taking place
in major cities in this country our mike
armstrong is in montreal where a
demonstration has just begun mike
is it peaceful and what kind of police
presence is there
it is very peaceful at this point the
chant we've just heard moments ago was
it's enough this event was called by
three organizations here in montreal
two black community groups and a third
group that fights police brutality
a montreal study last year looked at
police interceptions over the course of
four years from 2014
to 2017. those are incidents where
people were stopped but not
charged or ticketed it found black and
indigenous people were four times more
likely to be stopped by police
than white people arab people are twice
as likely to be stopped
and the trends by the way weren't
improving over time over that time those
four years they were actually getting
worse now we spoke to one of the
organizers earlier today
she said they called this protest
despite covid19
they asked participants to bring masks
and brought some to pass out
they've also asked people to keep two
meters apart something that's hard to do
in this crowd
but she said there is a movement out
there right across north america
and they had to take to the streets to
have their voices heard
there's a lot of rage there's a lot of
frustration
and that is happening right now and this
is why we want to
denounce it and not stay silent towards
it because silence
will not bring anything
now montreal's now montreal's had a lot
of protests that started peacefully and
turned violent in the past
a lot of them you can see police are out
in force tonight we've been told by a
source on the force that
all five platoons of montreal's riot
squad are on duty tonight
we will see them if things degenerate
but for the protesters
excuse me for the organizers here today
they say the idea is to start the event
here at montreal police headquarters to
take to the streets peacefully
and if something does happen they say it
won't be on them and they hope it
doesn't take away from their message
robin mike armstrong in montreal thanks
mike
after this break we'll take you back to
d.c where protesters are on the move
we want to take you back to washington
and our jackson prescott jackson is the
situation getting worse by the minute
there
it is robin we just had a bit of a tense
confrontation a few minutes ago with
police setting off a number of flash
bangs they're trying to get the crowd to
disperse here
the crowd has been trying to move we
believe toward the trump hotel and
they're being blocked by a police line
that said you know further back in the
crowd it is peaceful there's less
confrontation you've got people
having a sit in here in the street uh
generally speaking you know trying to
get the message across
and what happens is that there's a
select number of people who are
agitating and getting into it with
police
and when those confrontations happen
that's when police respond back to the
flash bangs and we believe there may
have been some tear gas deployed a short
time ago
it seems now like the group is back on
the move toward the direction of the
white house which is where this day
started out actually
do you get a sense though that the
crowds are dispersing or that police are
able to get a control of
get control of the situation
at this point it seems like we're in for
a long night here in washington the
mayor has just imposed a curfew
something she had been reluctant to do
earlier in the day saying she did not
believe it would be effective they've
also mobilized the dc national guard to
try and get a handle on things that's a
step that
many other cities have taken and over at
the white house complex which is just
one block behind us here where this day
started out a massive mobilization of
secret service and u.s parks police
the various jurisdictions that protect
that area as we've seen in other parts
of the country
it seems that there are more concerns as
night falls
that has been the case here as well the
thing i'll point out that's different
tonight is
uh the point that we seem to be at with
this protest right now is the point that
was not reached until well after sunset
last night
i were talking 10 or 11 o'clock last
night things are escalating sooner on in
the day today
despite hopes that things would be
calmer the other difference is that it
is one large cohesive protest whereas
yesterday
it was several smaller groups that had
broken up and moved throughout the city
tonight they're sticking together and in
larger numbers it seems and still no
word from the u.s president
none whatsoever he's inside the white
house at this hour he has to know that
thousands of protesters
are on his doorstep he watches this on
cable news but no word from him despite
pleas
from local officials across the country
for him to come forward
and offer some words that might offer
some comfort and perhaps de-escalate the
situation
all right jackson prosco in washington
dc thank you and stay
safe coming up anger beyond the borders
george floyd's death sparks protests
across the globe
demonstrations are taking place around
the world to show solidarity for the
protests in the u.s
in london thousands of people gathered
in trafalgar square with signs
while chanting george floyd they then
marched through the city walking past
the u.s embassy and the british
parliament
the demonstration defied the british
government's ban of mass gatherings
because of the pandemic
police did not interfere we've seen for
hundreds of years black people and
people of color
be absolutely abused and killed
on the streets and it's just getting
worse and worse we've had enough
and if they're not going to listen we're
going to scream louder and louder
and we're not going to stop until
something is done we've had enough
no justice no justice
in germany protesters poured into the
streets of berlin chanting black lives
matter and
i can't breathe some demonstrations in
the german capital have turned violent
police used tear gas and rubber bullets
to restore order
and more than 2 000 protesters converged
on the u.s embassy in copenhagen
the peaceful march wound its way to the
palace square as demonstrators chanted
no justice no peace and a more subdued
demonstration in iran where students
held up signs in solidarity
the supreme leader of the country
tweeting if you have colored skin
are walking the streets in the u.s you
can't be sure you'll be alive in the
next few minutes
that is the racism of america
doing all that i can
up next a young man's impassioned plea
in a country gripped by
anger and violence
you're watching global national
the hurt and anger sparked by the police
killing of george floyd has rippled
across the u.s
and around the world the video of his
death is haunting it is so hard to watch
and the scenes of the tense standoff
between protesters and police are
shocking
but in a time that seems chaotic there
are powerful calls for people to come
together
to make changes we leave you tonight
with some of those
poignant moments and a plea from a young
black man who is sharing his emotional
message
through song i'm robin gill thank you
for watching
good night
today we're asking our community for
peace
but i want to be very clear we are not
asking you
for patience and we are not asking you
for pacifism we're asking you to take
that energy
and use it not to destroy our
neighborhoods
but to destroy the historic culture
to destroy the systemic racism
[Music]
we lost humanity on that day and what
we're doing right now
in these protests in these moments as we
risk ourselves in this pandemic
is fighting for humanity
[Music]
well we use this as a moment to say that
we will not do what other cities have
done and in fact we will get better than
we've been
and i urge you
and you know who you are to think
long and hard about what you can and
should do
to devote the passion and the energy
that you showed
last night and wreaking havoc in our
city
to doing something different with your
life
and your talents i'm standing here
with my people face to face with this
crowd
and everybody's thinking how can we use
force and defeat
and i'm not having
[Music]
i'm a young black man
doing all that i can
to stand oh but when i look around
and i see what's being done to mankind
every day i'm being hard to just pray
my people don't want no trouble with
that enough strong goals
[Music]
i just wanna live
god protect me